he brought handcuffs with him this whole
thing was planned I think it's kind of
cool it's not cool it's trespassing and
that is breaking the rules
cool people make the rules they don't
break the rules and if those kids want
you to break the rules or not really
your friends oh who are you even talking
about I don't know I'm sorry I'm just
annoyed but while we're on the subject
your friend orange with the long black
nails and the cloak he concerns me he's
a genius hey guys okay everybody listen
up
April's friend Orin is here he's very
intense and very weird so if you end up
talking to him just make sure you don't
reveal anything personal about yourself
I remember you made me wear a leather
jacket that is the last time you and I
see each other for more than five
minutes
[Music]
howdy neighbors welcome to human farm
here's her animal feed please don't be
dams really really cool I like the
statement it's making that you know
we're all in cages in a way yeah it's
actually about death and the city yeah I
see that now
hi Oren no Oren I don't know how I'm
going to die wait are you asking me or
telling me hey can I talk to you for a
second yes please April and Andy are
about to get married
Wow Greta filters older than their
relationship weighs again should I
change my Brita filter I don't know it
depends on how frequently you use it
stay focused okay please look who
decided to join the party where's your
costume honey he's wearing a costume
he's going as lame but I think the
Batman costumes are way better
you should go wear that yeah I don't
think I'm gonna put on a costume because
I'm not really attending this party it's
at my house hey listen if you're mad
about something
no she just I'm not I'm not mad really
listen I feel like you are mad so maybe
you should just talk to us about it
man all right that was great thank you
thanks for that your fingers are salty
I'm gonna finish my work Orin no no
stamped hi guys remember how I told you
there was going to be a surprise later
well the surprise is you're not actually
at a dinner party you're at our wedding
all right let's do this
[Applause]
[Music]
bro
come
so for my painting I chose one of my
very favorite Greek myths the centaur
goddess dyaphena slaying a great stack
mmm it's stunning it's breathtaking
Jerry yeah really is exactly mortality
see I'd like to take each day at a time
there's nothing in the world we can't
accomplish if we try I have to go it's
been great talking hey you're here a
bachelor are you kidding me no he
brought Orin and is not some weird
morose mummy offense intended Orin let
this be a wake-up call about the way you
present yourself to the world I think it
will be cute together I asked you to do
one thing do you know how hard I've been
working to try to pull this together
before Ann gets here hey hey you're here
we weren't talking about you how are you
well it's Valentine's Day
and I'm single and I'm at a couple
Stan's we can't imagine a more
depressing place to be what about a
wedding where you used to go out with
the groom and you're the only one there
without a date so the bride makes you
dance to single ladies by yourself oh my
god does that happen to you baby let's
get a drink and then you and I are gonna
have some f-u-n well at least the music
seems about right
[Music]
I'm gonna see it what your pirate last
year yes this is my halloween costume
Andrew are you aware that your bathroom
faucet is leaking are you kidding me I
just stuffed a saucony yesterday what
else do they want me to do there's an
exposed wire above the bathtub as well
oh yeah I call it that because if you
take a shower and you touch the wire you
die yes that is accurate do you have a
toolbox yeah no home is complete without
a proper toolbox
here's April and Andy's a hammer half of
a pretzel baseball card some cartridge
that says Sonic and Hedgehog a scissor
half so why do you want this job
well I love cats and dogs sure are great
well you have all the qualifications you
went to a four-year college actually
when I went there it was just a two-year
college well you're not even technically
qualified to work at your current job oh
geez
you're fired get out no no you're not
fired but we're definitely going to have
to lower your salary
oh well fair's fair I am very very very
very frightened of animals this may not
be the job for you I know but my
therapist dr. Richard Nygard told me to
confront my fears you see dr. Richard
Nygard I'm in a guardian - would you say
my cast yes but just please don't give
me this job the spaying and neutering
tools do you think those fit humans and
is there a lock on the spaying room door
thank you so much for coming in thanks
for having me okay hello Orin thank you
so much for applying now leave hey give
him a chance what makes you qualified
for animal control
I studied zoology in college and I can
control animals with my mind get out
I made you say that
I liked him well that was a truly
depressing slate of candidates I think
you've got several options they're all
terrible but you have fun hey
criss cross we change up the music it
kind of sounds like the end of a movie
about a monk who killed himself
we should stay don't go back to
Indianapolis we should stay here okay
yeah yes it's a great city here you know
and there are great people and you've
made a lot of friends yeah what are you
gonna do go back to your old job and
hack up people's budgets stay here help
us build something I already accepted
the job I'm staying here that's good
yeah I think so I'm
[Music]
Oren's behind me isn't yeah yeah okay
okay so just keep your eyes on her don't
panic because you can smell fear we're
already talking part hi how are you good
how are you how's the work
how am I supposed to find the love of
Anne's life when it sounds like a
funeral in here
there's no changement as long as chris
is depressed I'm gonna go talk to Chris
you go help Ann she's not responding to
my top candidates so we're gonna have to
go with some wild cards got it in April
thanks for nothing why should I do
anything to help her because despite the
fact that all you do is give her a hard
time she would do this for you just go
hide under the table with your friend
Orrin yeah I see you weirdo okay this
party needs a little help I'll be right
back so are you going on like a
year-long walking tour of the set of the
Lord of the Rings and New Zealand er to
be honest with you I wasn't a fan of
Peter Jackson's interpretation so you
can put that one away I think we should
do more stuff like this you know I think
Pawnee needs an amazing arts program
maybe you should just drop everything
and coordinate it I'm not stupid
what is that supposed to mean it means
that the only reason you brought me here
is to distract me from the dog park you
hate this show I love this show what's
your favorite part the heavy-handedness
yes you know what I have to go talk to
councilman Jamm right now why are you
talking to councilman Jamm because I
told him about the dog park idea and he
loves it he thinks it's a great idea
he's gonna support my motion at the City
Council meeting tomorrow and he gave me
a really cool dental mirror to check out
my molars and our dispute aside you
should be careful with Jim he's a snake
I'm telling you yeah like I should trust
you out of all people right now whoa no
quiet weirdo aren't you supposed to be a
sheep no you are hey are you on the lot
is everything okay not really
Public Works put up a giant padlock on
the fence and a sign that says no
trespassing that probably doesn't apply
to us there's also a sign that says
especially Leslie no well Leslie no it
was a very common name there's a
professor in Copenhagen named Leslie
Knope they probably mean him do they
mean the professor yeah there's a
picture of you also and two huge
security guards holy mother of Malia and
Sasha I love them both equally okay it's
that stupid Harold who's behind this get
here and we will make a plan
how long do I have to do this until I
say so
oran stay in character
you